c'est un peu comme un baptême de l'air
mais dans un abattoir mais vous avez
l'air sympa alors nous découvrons alors
une chaîne de production
renversante un ballet 280000 poulet ils
sont parmi les mots chers d'europe
les prix sont 3 % plus bas qu'en france
ça n'a l'air de rien mais à grande
échelle
c'est une sacrée économie pour casser
les tarifs l'usiné mise en place un
système totalement mécanisée suspendu à
cette chaîne les carcasses passe en fait
d'atelier en atelier pour être découpées
sans aucune intervention humaine
toutes les bêtes sont pesées
automatiquement tout ensuite elles
défilent le long de la chaîne de
production
et petit à petit ça enlève les morceaux
en tout il y a trois salles celle ci en
haut et en bas les machines découpe
d'abord la tête puis enlève l'intérieur
et les membres petit à petit les poulets
se réduisent comme peau de chagrin
[Musique]
les employés n'interviennent qu'à de
rares étapes qui ne peuvent être
réalisées par des machines
pour finaliser la découpe des 180 milles
poulet
[Musique]
tous les produits arrivent ici ils sont
préparés dans différentes palettes
chacun prend ce dont il a besoin et
c'est là que nous allons trouver la
réponse au mystère des morceaux kfc les
carcasses qui arrive qui s'ils pèsent
entre 1 kg 7 et 3 kg
elles sont réparties en fonction des
exigences de chaque client et donc là
par exemple c'est celui que vous appelez
un petit poulet oui ce sont des petits
regardez c'est tout petit ce sont ceux
de kfc non les leurs sont bien plus gros
vous en avez ici lusine réserve ses plus
gros poulet kfc
il pèse en moyenne 2 kg 5
car lens et lui réclame des poulets bien
dodues pour avoir les tendeurs si les
plus généreux le morceau préféré des
consommateurs français
vous voyez les filets de blanc c'est ce
qui est plus cher avec les aiguillettes
ce sont vraiment les deux parties les
plus chers ces blancs de poulet valent
de l'or
l'abattoir les revendre et à kfc 4 euros
du kilo deux fois plus cher qu'une
cuisse ou qu un pilon
lusine doit donc se procurer des poulets
particulièrement gros mais aussi bon
marché pour les obtenir
les industriels ont tout simplement créé
de toutes pièces une volaille nouvelle
génération ultra performante
[Musique]